a lot of democratic governments are
passing laws you know in the name of
protecting children in the name of
fighting crime in the name of fighting
terror that are using solutions that
involve censorship and surveillance so
you know putting in mechanisms to censor
child pornography putting in mechanisms
to censor material that's violating
copyright putting in more power to the
government to conduct surveillance of
what Internet users are doing and the
concern is that these mechanisms are
going to be abused and so you've seen
you know in a number of countries where
they've put mechanisms in place to
censor child pornography that other
websites end up getting censored that
aren't actually child porn and concerns
about the extent to which the people
running these systems might apply their
own agendas and abuse their power to
censor more material than they were
actually mandated to censor in the
United States and in Western Europe
because of concern about cybercrime
there is an increasing tendency to pass
laws that allow law enforcement to
access our information to follow what
we're doing to demand the companies
handover information with less and less
due process and less and less you know
fewer and fewer mechanisms for
accountability in the United States if
the government wants to read your mail
it's pretty straightforward there needs
to be a warrant but if a government
agency wants to look at your email and
if your emails over a hundred and eighty
days old they don't need anything they
can just ask for it and so there are a
lot of issues online where surveillance
is much more pervasive in our online
lives than it is in our offline lives
and I think a lot of you know most
people
in the United States and the Democratic
West are not aware of that because when
police officers come into your house or
come into your office and they go
through your files they go through your
desk they go through your drawers and
cabinets it's pretty obvious that
happened if they do the equivalent in
your email in your you know online
storage spaces and your Facebook you
know you don't know you have no idea it
ever happened
and so you're not going to you know
raise a fuss about it because you didn't
know it happened and you don't know who
was responsible and so when power is
being abused in digital networks we need
to make sure people know and that people
who are abusing power held accountable
we need to make sure that we're not
allowing governments or companies to get
away with abusing that power so it's an
ordinary Internet user there's quite a
number of things you can do to defend
your rights online first of all is you
have to be aware you need to be paying
attention to how your social networks
how the Internet services you depend on
are collecting your information you
should be asking questions about how
they share that information with the
government with other companies who can
access that information under what
circumstances what are the company's
policies about taking down content or or
blocking content so first of all is
understanding what their policies and
their practices are and then second of
all is that you need to make noise if
you don't like what they're doing we've
seen a number of situations where
companies do sometimes change their
policies if their users and customers
are organizing and protesting against
those policies you see it sometimes just
in terms of the fees they charge but
sometimes you've seen it also just in
terms of their privacy and security
practices or the way the terms under
which you can use a real name or or how
you're identified online you know
there's there's different ways you can
push back I think we need to be
exercising our powers as
Zoomers so when you're deciding what
what internet service provider to use or
what email service to use or even you
know how you're going to use a
particular social network think about
whether that company is is making an
effort to protect your rights and you
know be careful about how you use that
service so that you don't expose
yourself in in ways that that you don't
want